The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: All right.
So let's get started.
So last time, we had
talked about factorization
in the effective theory.
And there is one type
of factorization,
which is this hard-collinear
factorization, which
is a factorization between the
low energy physics described
by the operator and the
Wilson coefficients.
And we decided we
wanted to think
about that in the following
way, as having convolutions
between variables that appear
in the Wilson coefficients
and variables that
appear in the operator.
And the way that we
can think about that
is just what the most general
possible thing is that we can
write down for the Wilson
coefficients and of course,
it can depend on large momenta.
And so large momenta here
includes the label operator.
So large momenta always show
up in Wilson coefficients
and in this case,
that includes momenta
that are the large
component, the order lambda 0
component of collinear fields.
So this is hard-collinear
factorization
and it just comes out in
a natural, standard way
in this effective
theory because we've
set up the effective theory
to have the right low energy
degrees of freedom.
So even though it's a
little more complicated
than just a simple
product, we see
what the variables are that
can connect the two things just
by power counting, essentially.
The large momenta are the
ones that are order lambda 0.
We can do this generically
if we recall the definition
of our Wilson line.
We can see how this
would carry over
to a generic case in
the following way.
So that was one way of
defining the Wilson line.
And as an operator, we
had relations as well.
So we had this relation
and in particular, we
could take this to any power
and that just takes the p bar
to any power like that.
So you can really
think of this as given
any function of this
operator i m bar
dot d you can always write
that as a Wilson line,
a function of p bar,
and a Wilson line.
And what you want to do is
you want to stick these Wilson
lines in the
operator and you want
to put this function in
the Wilson coefficient.
So you could think, lets
me start with operator.
I can throw in i m bar dot
d's because these guys are
order lambda 0, these are
collinear derivatives.
I could just allow it to
stick as many of those
as I like in my operator.
But given that I put in
any function of them,
I could always do
this and the right way
of thinking about it is
that this function here
is determined by matching.
It's your Wilson coefficient.
And that's what we were
effectively doing up here.
But in some sense of
our general discussion
you can see that even if you had
multiple places in the operator
where you could insert
these derivatives, then
you would just do this.
And what would happen is
at the end of the day,
you get a function of all
the possible large momenta
that you can form
from the operator.
So maybe one more line.
So think of it, you can
always separate out.
Make a split like
we did over there
with the integral
over some variable
and then leave something that
you can stick in your operator,
make it like this.
So this could go in
the operator and then
that's the coefficient.
AUDIENCE: If I stick
this in [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: Well,
here I didn't write it.
So if I wanted to
put in i m bar dot
d's, I'd stick them between.
Right?
If I wanted to use the formula.
If I wanted to use
this kind of logic
I wouldn't have
written this and I
would have said let me stick an
arbitrary function of i m bar
dot d in here.
AUDIENCE: But Between
before you even write--
IAIN STEWART: It has to
be between them because
of the gauge invariance.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So before you write
down the Wilson line.
So say you start and say, OK--
IAIN STEWART: Oh, yeah,
so there's still--
right.
Right, right, right.
This Wilson line here
came from this h.
So that's still
going to be true.
And what I'm saying, if you
think about this operator,
I could dress it up by
putting any function of i
m bar dot d's right in here
because that would still be
same order and gauge invariant.
AUDIENCE: OK, but
this an alternative--
IAIN STEWART: But then
if I use this formula,
it would sort of push this w.
That would cancel there
and then this w comes back
and then you get the if.
OK.
So in general, the right
way of thinking about this
is as follows.
We can encode this
in some notation
by just setting up a convenient
set of building blocks
which are gauge
invariant objects
under the collinear
gauge transformations.
And so we need to
have a fermion field,
but we know that
the fermion field,
generically we can make it
gauge invariant by multiplying
by Wilson line like that.
And because of this, what we
were just discussing here,
generically, we can be in
our Wilson coefficient,
sensitive to the
momentum of this object.
And so we can denote that by
defining the following thing,
which is just a chi field that
carries some momentum which
is the overall large momentum
of this product of fields.
And sometimes this guy goes by
the name of the quark jet field
because if you were to produce
a quark in the hard scattering
process, the quark would be
represented in your operator
by this w dagger c.
The Wilson coefficients
would talk to that quark
through the large
momentum and that quark,
in the low energy theory,
would evolve into a jet.
So it goes by that name.
You could also think
of it as a parton field
because as it turns out and
as we'll talk about later on,
if you were to think about the
parton distribution function
and what pulls a quark
out of the proton,
it's exactly this operator.
And then that quark's
momentum, what
momentum that quark carries
is exactly picked out
by this delta function as well.
So these are the
objects you'll usually
want to work in terms of.
We can do something similar for
the gluon, which is a curly b
and I'm going to define it.
If we wanted to get a
gluon, the natural thing
is to use a field strength
because then you get a gluon
without any derivatives.
But I want my object
to be dimension one,
so I'm going to define
it in the following way.
So here's a field
strength commutator
of covariant derivatives, these
are collinear derivatives.
And I throw Wilson lines around
it to make it gauge invariant,
and then to make it dimension
one I throw in a 1 over p bar.
And if you start
expanding this out,
then the first term will
be the a n perp gluon
and so you have this b just has
a n perp gluon in the same way
that the first kind of
order term in this chi
is just to the fermion if
I set the Wilson line to 1.
OK?
So it's starting out as
a perpendicular gluon
but it's dressed up in a way
that makes it gauge invariant
in dimension one.
And then just like we did here,
we can put a subscript on it
with a omega to say that we
fixed the large momentum of it
and sometimes there's a
convention that that's done,
you have to decide if you
want the Wilson line--
I mean, the delta function
to be a w minus p bar or w
minus p bar dagger.
Anyway, it doesn't really matter
that much because it's just
a sign of what you mean by a w.
If it's an outgoing gluon,
this is a more convenient
convention.
OK, and so this delta
function here and this p bar
here, when I put these
square brackets, what
I mean by that is that they
don't know how to act outside.
They just act on the
operators inside.
So these are objects
that exist by themselves
and they don't care
about other things that
are multiplying them later.
So that's the gluon
analog of the quark.
So it turns out that we
can show the following.
That if you want
to build operators
that are subleading
order, a complete set
of things to do
that is as follows.
It's this chi n, the
bn perp, and then you
could also need p perps.
And then you could also
have ultrasoft fields,
where it's really
kind of similar to how
you're used to building
operators in effective field
theories.
But if you just want to talk
about the collinear sector,
the only things you need are
this chi n this bn field,
and then p perps
and no other things.
AUDIENCE: That's to
go just one order?
IAIN STEWART: All orders.
AUDIENCE: So why
aren't there any--
IAIN STEWART: I'll
talk about it.
Yeah.
I'll show you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
I mean, intuitively
you would think
these are the physical
degrees of freedom, right?
There's two of them
so that's intuitive.
But I'll show you how you get
rid of all the other ones.
It kind of matches up
with what you want.
You could think that these are
the physical gluons that you're
producing and your operators can
be set up so that there's not
any spare use components.
OK.
So we'll get there.
So let me introduce
a bit of notation.
I have to do.
So let's consider this thing.
A covariant
derivative sandwiched
with Wilson lines on
either side and this i dn
here is like p bar plus.
So it just involves the
collinear gluon field.
So then if I have that operator
and I just take n bar i dn,
then that's p bar.
if I take i dn perp
mu, then you can
show that this guy is p
perp u plus g bn perp mu.
So this one is just a relation
we talked about before.
This one is not as obvious,
but if you take this guy,
you can let this derivative
p perp act on the Wilson line
or act through.
If it acts through,
that's this term.
If it acts on, then I can
manipulate the operator
so that it is exactly this form.
And part of that comes
from the fact that--
I can explain it to you here.
I have it in my notes and
you can look at it later,
but let me just
explain it in words.
If you looked at the
term in this commutator
that was other order, where the
i m bar dot d was sitting here.
It would hit the Wilson line.
You'd get 0.
So that term was
just put in to make
it look like a field strength.
OK?
So really you have i m bar dot
d dn perp, without the comma,
without the brackets.
But then this combination
here, you can use the identity
that we had with it
and basically if you
push this guy
through here, you're
canceling the p bar so it's
just giving you the Wilson line.
So that's basically how
you go from here to here.
OK?
So basically what
this is saying is
I don't need to consider
covariant derivatives because I
can instead consider
p perps and b
perps and that's equally good.
OK.
Now if you do a similar type
of thing in the n component,
then you can derive a
similar type of object.
So this is the same
object as we have
over here, but instead
of having an i dn perp,
I'd have an n dot d.
So d dot n perp
replaced n dot d.
And that looks like
it could be something
that you'd build operators out
of and and also, furthermore,
why not have operators that
depend on this n dot partial?
OK?
So for p bar, we don't
have to worry about that.
So OK, I said we'll include
this, we'll include that.
I didn't say we have include
this, this, and this.
So there's three things I
have to argue away here.
The derivatives that
are p bars, those just
go into the Wilson coefficient.
So if we had p bar chi n
comma omega, for example,
then that's omega
chi n comma omega
and this is put into
the Wilson coefficient.
So that's why we don't have
to worry about having p bars.
In some sense, we
do have p bars.
They're all in the
Wilson coefficients.
So it's really these
other two that we
have to worry more
about and those actually
can be simplified using
the equation of motion.
So if you have i n dot
p partial on chi n, then
equation of motion
when you write it out
in terms of these
objects, it has some form
and basically, you can just
get rid of those terms.
So the equation of motion
allows us to get rid of i n dot
partials that are on chi n's.
So that's why we don't
have to worry about those.
And this is just like saying
that in our leading order
action, there wasn't
i n dot partial.
But that's just
like saying there
was time derivatives
in our leading order
action in some standard
effective field theory.
But then in the higher
dimension operators,
you can always use the
equations of motion
to get rid of those
time derivatives.
And here we're using
the equation of motion
to get rid of i n dot partial.
So it appears in the
leading order action,
but then we don't have to have
it in any other subleading
operator and that's why it's
not one of the ones that's
included in the list.
And if you had i n dot
partial on curly b,
that's also part
of the equations
of motion of the gluon field.
Now when you do the gluon
equations of motion,
there's components
because it's a vector
and one of the other
components allows
you to get rid of the n dot b.
So there's another term
that you can rearrange,
and I won't write it out because
the equation is rather messy
but give you some idea.
There's another
component that looks
like this where I can get rid
of all the n dot curly b's
using the gluon equation.
So the gluon
equations of motions
allows me to get rid
of both of these things
and basically after
I've done that, I just
have the objects that
I've told you we can use.
So after using
equations of motion,
we can get down
to those objects.
And any other thing
that you might dream up
can be reduced to these objects.
So I'm not saying that I went
through a complete list here.
For example, what if you had
a commutator of 2 d n perps?
Right?
You might say, oh,
that's some new thing.
It's one of these.
You can also reduce that too.
So let me list that
one just to give you
some idea that there's others
you might think of dreaming up.
So you can reduce all
of this to be that.
OK, so for the
collinear sector this
is enough to build higher
dimension operators, just
these three.
And then for the ultrasoft
sector, so I guess this is two.
We do need ultrasoft derivatives
and ultrasoft field strengths
and ultrasoft quarks.
So this part is really
just similar to the story
that you'd have for a standard
low energy effective field
theory.
Like integrating out
a massive particle,
you can use the
equation of motion.
One thing that is
worth commenting about
is the connection
between one and two.
So one is collinear
and two is ultrasoft
and prior you might think, well,
they're totally independent.
But we saw last time that
reparamaterization invariance
connects them.
So if I've decided that
this is the type of basis
I want to use for
my operators, then
what is the
reparameterization connection?
You can rewrite what we
said last time in terms
of these curly d's because
it basically just means
moving the Wilson lines that we
had in this formula last time.
They were around the
ultrasoft operator last time
and if I just move them over
to the collinear operator,
then I get this curly d.
Right?
So the RPI connection
is connecting
the curly d collinear
to the d ultrasoft
and then you can write this guy
as the p perp plus the b perp.
And likewise if you do the
same for the n bar sector
and you move the Wilson lines
from this term to that term,
then it looks like
these two combinations.
So that's just rewriting what
we had before but now in terms
of this type of notation.
OK?
So that's enough to build
operators at higher order
and then we write down
Wilson coefficients
for those operators that are
functions of a large momentum
and then we start doing
physics with them.
So any questions about that?
AUDIENCE: For the
equations of motion,
you always just use the leading
order equation of motion--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --into a
higher order term?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, these are
the L0 equations of the motion.
That's what I'm doing
here or writing here.
Yeah, there's one more actually.
There's three but it's only
needed at some very high order.
OK.
So the next thing I
want to talk about
before we start doing
explicit examples
and going through
processes is how loops
work in this effective theory.
And we're going to have to come
back and talk about our grid
that we have for the split
up of momenta and how
should we actually think
about it in practice
and then we'll also deal with
how matching and running work.
So I'm going to do this in
the context of an example
and again, I'm just going to
pick the simplest example that
has only one jet just to make
our lives a little bit simpler.
So we'll consider our
heavy, light current
and I think actually
once you see
how it works in
this example, you'll
understand what all the general
features are of doing loops
in SCET.
So we had operators
that we constructed,
lowest order operator.
And let me write it
in this way which
was prior to making
our field redefinition.
I could just write it
this way if I want.
And gamma for beta s gamma
is a tensor operator.
And there's a photon field,
which is a field strength,
f mu nu.
So let's just think of
that as all part of gamma.
OK, and that's
also appearing here
and I could use the spin
structure properties
of these things to reduce
the sigma and mu nu
but that's not really going
to be part of our story
so let's not bother with that.
So what I do?
I just compute the QCD
loops and the SCET loops
and I compare them.
And if SCET is the
right effective theory
for this limit where I
have an energetic photon
and am back to back with
an energetic strange quark,
then I should match all
the infrared divergences
in that QCD
computation, I should
be able to extract a
matching coefficient,
I should be able
to determine what
the C is from that
calculation, and I should
be able to run the operator.
I should be able to
make this into m s bar,
do some renormalization
of this operator,
and then do some renormalization
group evolution of that Wilson
coefficient.
Well, let's just think
about computing the graphs.
So we have to decide, when
we compute the graphs,
how to regulate them?
Right?
And we need to use the
same infrared regulator
in the full theory and
the effective theory.
So here's how I'm
going to regulate them.
We could do this
different ways and it's
useful to understand that
various answers that we get
are independent
of the regulator.
So I'm going to take p
squared not equal to 0
for the strange quark.
So there's infrared
divergences associated
with the strange
quirk and I'm going
to take p squared not
equal to 0 for them.
I'm going to use dim
reg for the heavy quark.
So I could take the b
quark to also be offshell.
That would make the formulas
even more complicated.
So instead of doing
that, I'm just
going to allow epsilon
to regulate the b quark.
These guys are
pretty easy to track
so that won't be a problem.
And I'm going to
use Feynman gauge.
I don't have to do that,
but that's a nice gauge
for doing calculations.
So what are the diagrams
where I have my photon
and I have a vertex
diagram like this
and then I have wave
function renormalization?
And so let me, in the
usual kind of cavalier way,
denote the wave function
renormalization, which
is just the multiplication
by the appropriate z factors.
My diagram's like that.
And this is a standard
QCD calculation
and we can carry it out.
And what does the
answer look like?
So this diagram
here has double logs
and single logs that
involve p squared, which
is our IR regulator, and then it
has some terms that are finite,
which I'll just note by--
so p here is the momentum of
our strange quark going out
and pb is the momentum
of our b quark coming in.
And we're not going to talk
much about these finite terms
but what I mean
by finite here is
terms with no IR divergences.
The IR divergences are these
single logs and double logs
and then there's some remainder
that I can write that way.
I'm expanding it
for small p squared.
So p squared is not
equal to 0 but I
take the limit p
squared goes to 0
and then that limit, these
are the IR singularities.
And then there's some
function of b dot pb, which
is just an order one thing.
And then b squared, of
course, is pb squared.
So that's sort of the
remaining kinematic variables
this could possibly depend on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
IAIN STEWART: No.
AUDIENCE: Is it finite?
IAIN STEWART: It's
really finite.
So yeah.
Yeah, so let's see.
Yeah, I guess I carried
out the so there
is a z ten for the tensor
and when I write this--
yeah, let's see.
So, OK.
Let me do this.
I think it's better.
So I added up all these graphs
and I want to add one more.
So there's a counterterm
for the tensor field.
So let me change
what I was going
to say and do it this way.
So the sum of these
four graphs is this.
OK?
So there's no UV divergences.
And I'll just tell you what the
z factors for these three are,
then you could figure
out what this graph is
by subtracting the two.
So the tensor current in QCD
has a z factor, looks like that.
There is a z for
the heavy quark.
And if I include the
finite residue as well as
the divergent pieces,
this looks like this.
I think I'm going
to have to make one
adjustment to my formula here.
Let me just fix something here.
Yeah.
So if I want it to be the way I
say, then what do I have to do?
So this guy should
be three halves
and there will be
one more divergence.
I think that's right.
So this 2 over
epsilon ir here is
that 1 over epsilon ir
and the UV renormalization
is taken care of once
I have the z tensor.
There's divergences in
this diagram in these ones.
but there's one left
over, and that's
taken care of by z tensor.
So there's no 1 over epsilon UVs
after I take care of this guy.
So that's just by the definition
of what z tensor should be
and then everything
else is as I wrote.
So there's either
divergences that
are associated to this strange
quirk offshellness, that's
these two terms.
There's an IR divergence
associated, a heavy quark going
onshell, that's that term.
And that's the sum of diagrams.
OK, so what about SCET?
So there's going to be, in
SCET, collinear diagrams
and ultrasoft diagrams.
So I'm going to use Feynman
gauge for everything again.
This is not something
I have to do,
but this is what
I'm going to do.
So let's start with
the ultrasoft loops.
So there's a vertex graph.
So using the notation that we've
adopted where the collinear
quarks are dashed and the
heavy quarks are double lines,
we have a diagram
that looks like that.
There's some free factor.
Let's focus on what
the loop looks like.
So this loop here, the k
that's going through this loop
is just a residual k.
There's no label k for
this loop because it's
an ultrasoft gluon.
So when we write down all
the terms in this loop,
it's just standard field theory.
There's nothing
special about it.
Since I'm taking the
strange quirk offshell,
the propagator that I get is
this shifted iconal propagator
where basically the
fact that it's offshell
it gives me this
extra term there.
That's regulating some
minor divergences.
And we want that because we want
to regulate the IR divergences
in the same way in the full
theory of the effective theory.
This is proportional to that
and if I put in all the factors.
So it does have double
logs of the p squared,
doesn't have single
and actually if we look
at the double logs,
the coefficients
also don't match
with what we had over there.
And so there's going to be
some other diagrams that
are going to involve double
logs of p squared as well.
One thing that we
can note here is
that if you think about
the scales in the problem,
remember that our loop
integral was totally
homogeneous in the
power counting,
the lambdas were
totally homogeneous.
And if you think about
p squared scaling
like lambda squared,
which is natural size
for an external collinear
momentum, all right.
If p squared scales
like lambda squared then
so does p squared
over m bar dot p.
And this is a
dimension one thing
and this is the
ultrasoft scale, right?
For some ultra soft
momentum and so
if you want to look
at these logarithms
and you ask, what scale is
this effective field theory
diagram sensitive to?
It's sensitive to
the ultrasoft scale.
So the logs are not
large logs, they're
order 1 logs as
long as mu squared
mu is of order
lambda squared, which
is the scale for the
ultrasoft momentum.
And that's what we expect
from this ultrasoft diagram,
that it's telling us about
physics at the ultra soft scale
and that's what we
see setting things
up, doing the calculation.
So you could also think
about a wave function diagram
with an ultra soft
gluon, but this guy 0's
out since in Feynman gauge you
just get n mu n mu, which is 0.
So there's no so z for
the collinear quark
field from an
ultrasoft loop is 0.
That wouldn't necessarily
be true in some other gauge,
but in some other gauge this
diagram would also change.
All the diagrams would change.
And so if there was a non-zero
contribution in this diagram,
it would just be taking
care of gauge invariance.
And then finally,
there's ultrasoft loop
on the heavy quark.
And that's an HQET
diagram, has nothing
to do with the collinear quark.
So from that diagram
we would just
get the z factor, which is the
appropriate z factor in HQET
with r regulator.
If I specify ultraviolet
and infrared divergences,
that's this, and this
infrared divergence here
is actually exactly the same as
the one that we had over here.
OK, so the ultrasoft
sector, there's
nothing really tricky about it.
It's just write down the
diagrams, do the loops.
AUDIENCE: So for
the [INAUDIBLE],,
isn't that IR divergences
of those diagrams
cancel with every
automation [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: So what
are we looking at, right?
So it depends on what
we're looking at here.
And so, yes, in general
that would be true, right?
If you were calculating
some cross-section, which
was IR finite
cross-section and that,
of course, would depend
on defining what you
mean by measuring this quark.
Right?
So the IR divergence would
become some physical scale
like the mass of a jet.
The IR divergences would
turn into something physical
if you put this into a
physical cross-section.
And that's exactly
basically what would happen.
These p squareds would
become the mx squareds
that we talked about when we
talked about beta s gamma.
But here what we're
interested in doing
is a matching calculation.
So we fix the
external state, still
have a particular
number of partons,
and we want to compare the
full theory calculation
with the effective theory.
The effective theory
should reproduce
the infrared divergences.
So really all we
care about is not
that this is infrared
finite, but rather
that the effective theory has
the same infrared divergences.
And we'll see that
in the end when
you can think about is
rather than canceling in
for divergences as you're
thinking in the full theory,
we've matched the full theory
onto the effective theory
and that matching gives
us the Wilson coefficient.
And then we take effective
theory and all the cancelations
that you're thinking about
between real and virtual graphs
will occur in the
effective theory too.
So you can just think
about the effective theory
virtual-real graphs, then the
cancelation will take place
there.
But then you're thinking
about that cancelation
later, at a lower scale,
which is what you actually
want to do.
Because what I just was
telling you about IR
divergences becoming different
things in the final state
becomes very trivial once
you're in the effective theory
and we'll see sort of exactly
how that works later on.
But first we have to
talk about linear graphs.
So in the collinear
graphs we had
graphs like this one where
we can take a gluon out
of the vertex here.
That corresponds to taking
it out of the Wilson line.
So let's label the graph
in the following way.
This would be k plus p this
will be p This will be k.
And if we follow our
rules for what this is,
we would write a sum over
labels and then an integral
over residuals.
And let me put the
residual integral
in dimensional organization.
Let me try to squeeze
in everything,
which won't be possible.
So I'm going to write
out the components
to make clear whose
residual on whose label.
So in the denominator
there's one more term.
So the plus guys
are always residual,
the perp and the minuses
are always labeled.
The short way of saying what
I'm trying to squeeze in here.
So the denominator has these
three terms, this guy here,
this guy here,
and this guy here.
And when I label the
diagram like this,
you should think
that each of these
has a label and residual part.
So k you can think of as a pair,
k label, k residual for now.
And remember the
importance of doing this.
The importance of
doing this was related
to always being able to
identify what the lowest order
term was on the right here.
OK?
And that actually
becomes more important
once you start to think
about diagrams where
you would add like an extra
ultrasoft gluon somewhere
in this picture.
Then, of
Course when that ultrasoft
gluon feeds its way
through this loop,
you gotta make
sure that it's only the lowest
order piece that's showing up.
In this case here, we
just have a collinear loop
and we don't have any
sort of real ultrasoft
momenta from ultrasoft particles
besides the heavy quark, which
is just an external
particle to the loop.
So what we want to
do with this is we
want to turn it back
into an integral.
Just let me say it this way.
And if it wasn't for
these restrictions here,
then that's very easy, actually.
and then I'll talk
about why it's true.
I claim that if we
ignored the restrictions
and those restrictions are
ensuring that we don't double
count between our collinear
and our ultrasoft degrees
of freedom.
So they are important, but
let's ignore them for a minute.
If we do ignore them, we
would just get the following.
Where I just basically stop
thinking about residuals
and labels, write everything
as a full momentum,
and write down exactly the
same thing I just wrote.
So this is a full
k squared and this
is a full k plus p squared.
OK?
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to first ignore
these restrictions
and then I'm going
to tell you how it would
work, how this actually
does turn into this.
What are the rules
for doing that.
And then I'll come
back and I'll tell you
what these extra conditions do.
So really this looks
like maybe it's trivial,
but we should think about it.
And it's almost
trivial but not quite.
So really what
we're doing here is
we're combining back together
labels and residual momentum,
right?
And the place that we
have to worry about that
is in the perp in
the minus space.
And recall we had
the grid and the grid
is sort of our way of
guiding, our guidance
to see how to put
things back together.
So we had vectors that
lived in this space
and this is the label
and then there's
the residual, if we want
to point to some place
in that space.
This picture was like a
Wilsonian effective field
theory because the picture
makes you think of sharp edges.
But the real effective
theory that we're doing
is a continuum one
and so you have
to expand your
brain a little bit
and think that each of
the boxes in this picture
is actually an
infinite space as well,
because the residual space
doesn't have restrictions
like that that would
spoil Lorentz symmetry.
So each grid point really is
specifying an infinite space
of residual momenta.
And it's R4 or Minkowski space,
so the momenta components
are real numbers and
there's some rules.
So what are the rules?
So I'll tell you what the
rules are without restrictions
for now and then we'll
come back and I'll
tell you what the rules
are with restrictions.
So rule number one
is the simplest,
and it just says that
say I had the following,
I'll use a one
dimensional notation.
Say I had a sum over kl's and
an integral over all kr's.
Well that's just the same
as not having split it up
and doing an integral
over everything.
Because we split this thing
into boxes and if we really
integrate over all boxes
and sum over all labels,
then we should just get
back the full integration
over all the momenta.
So that's true for each,
for minus and perp momenta.
But really what we have to
do is we have to do this
with some integrand, right?
So the type of integrand
that we have is following.
If you think about
the components
that we're talking about here,
which are the minus and perp
ones, then in our
integrand up there,
there's no minus
or perp residuals.
So it's just a
function of the labels.
Right?
And so what that
says effectively
is that this is a constant
function in this box,
in each of the boxes.
And effectively, the way that
you use this formula is you
do the following.
You say, well, if it's a
constant function in the box,
I could evaluate it at a
different point in the box
and I'd still get
the same value.
So in particular,
I could evaluate
it k label plus k
residual and then I
can use that
formula there to say
that this is just an
integral with a continuous k
of the function evaluated
at that continuous k.
So that's the way
that number one works.
We are integrating functions
that are constant in the boxes
and so then it's
kind of trivial,
how to put the
boxes back together.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So this d kl division
doesn't have kl plus--?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, so
what I mean by it is--
yeah.
So I'm using here for each
minus or perp momenta,
one dimensional notation.
Yeah, and so I have
three of these.
I have to do this.
And for each one of them it's
true that what I'm saying.
But of course, if I tried
to write that on the board
then it would confuse
the point, I think,
which is, in some
sense, a simple point.
OK?
So this is, in
some sense, saying
that this whole split
up that we were doing
was not really needed.
We could've just written a
continuous integral and that's
kind of what this
is saying, right?
We could have just written
a continuous interval
and not worried so much
about all the split
up that we were doing.
The place that we have
to be careful about
is these restrictions, and
we'll come back to that.
And the other place that
we have to be careful about
is when you have the
multiple expansion.
But as long as you take care
of that, then basically this
is always happening.
So the reason why this
works is the following.
For every label loop momentum
that there is in any diagram,
there's always going to be some
corresponding residual that's
not specified by delta functions
in terms of external momenta.
And effectively, therefore
that we can absorb in order
to do what we just said.
So we can always go back from
this discrete type notation
back to a continuous notation.
The discrete notation
was just helping
us to set up the expansion
and be careful about it,
but we can always go back
to the continuous one
because there's always a
kr that has this property.
OK.
So now in general
though, you might have
some more complicated thing.
And if I'm going to
give you some rules
I should give you
a complete set.
So we have to append our list
of rules by the following one.
So if I thought about doing
what I just said over here
but I went to some higher
order, then what could happen?
Well then these kr minus and
kr our perps could show up.
They'd never show up in the
denominator of our propagators
if they were just
collinear propagators,
but they could show up at
some point in the numerator.
And we need actually a rule like
this one, which would be clear
if we were regulating d kr in
dimensional regularization,
that the power of divergences
are getting set to 0.
And that is basically to
maintain the run symmetry
in the residual space we
need a rule like this for j
greater than 0.
So that doesn't come
into our calculation,
but included for completeness.
So when would these
integral kr actually do
something non-trivial?
It would do
something non-trivial
if we had an ultrasoft
loops and collinear
loops at the same time.
So in the case where we
just have collinear loops,
it's basically up to this
issue about the restrictions
that we'll talk about.
It's basically
that we just could
have done everything
as continuous
and ignored this split.
But if we have both
ultrasoft particles that
are participating through the
loops and/or then in general
these will give
non-trivial loop momenta
in the residual momenta.
And hence there will be
some that we can't just
absorb in the fashion
that we just said.
So there will be, in this
situation, residual momenta.
Some residual momenta will
be absorbed in the same way
to turn the integrals
into continuous ones,
but other ones
won't be absorbed.
And that's because the
ultrasoft propagators rate
would involve the lr plus,
the lr minus, and the lr perp
in the denominator, so we
don't have this rule to apply.
We can't do what we said
here with the constant boxes
because now the functions are
depending on that variable.
So we just have to
do the integral.
So you could have something
that looks like just
in a schematic formula.
Let's have there
be 2 kr and an lr.
We're in kind of an
obvious notation.
I'm saying that the function
could depend on lr residual,
it doesn't depend
on kr residual.
So we absorb kr back into
the sum to make it continuous
and then this integral
we just have to do.
OK, but we're still, in the
end, just doing an integral.
So this guy come from ultrasoft
propagators, for example.
OK?
So those are the different
cases that you can get.
But nevertheless, even if
you have ultrasoft particles
and propagators
floating around, there
will always be a residual
momentum associated to
of what we were doing
over here that you
can absorb in the
same way I stated,
so let's proceed along these
lines and see where it takes us
and then we'll come
back and put in
this additional restrictions.
AUDIENCE: Do we ever have
to do a discrete sum?
Like is there a sum over ll?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, so you
never have to do a discrete sum.
AUDIENCE: That's good.
IAIN STEWART: Yep.
The discrete sum is really
just a way of thinking
and I'll show you in
a minute that you even
can avoid thinking about it
once you know what to do.
So it's guiding you
towards the right answer
but it's not really
something that you
have to think about
this grid picture.
It's really just if
you get confused,
you can always think about it
but if you're not confused,
you don't have to
think about it.
OK, so this guy is what we said,
proportional to what we said.
It's just in this case, the
reason why it was so simple
is because k residual is
one component of this guy,
and then there's these
other three, right?
And the other three,
we just absorb
the sum and the
integral back together
and there's nothing
further to talk about.
So that's why this is, in
some sense, very simple.
So we just do that,
and what do we get?
Get some 1 over epsilons, we
get some logs of p squared,
and I'm putting in
even the constant term
since it's pretty simple.
4 minus pi squared over 6.
So if you think about
where this came from,
there was a place
that this Wilson line
came from was attaching
this guy over here
and then integrating out
that offshell propagator.
So this is a vertex diagram.
We had a vertex diagram,
which is an ultrasoft gluon,
and now we've added an
identical type up topology.
Except we drew it
different because this line
was offshell so we drew
it as a Wilson line
and that's the right way
of thinking about it.
But if you think about
where it came from,
it was the same
topology and we've
added another vertex diagram.
So the effective
theory has two type
of vertex diagrams,
this collinear
one and the ultrasoft
one and we're
going to add them together.
And in this one,
you see the logs
are minimized at a
different scale, mu squared
of order p squared, which is
the right scale for a collinear
loop.
Because remember, the
collinear particles
lived at a larger p squared
than the ultrasoft ones.
So there's a larger scale that
would minimize these loops,
it's a collinear scale.
So the effective theory
is capturing the physics
at that scale.
Squeeze in another diagram here.
If we do the collinear wave
function renormalization,
then this is non-zero.
This was 0 for the
ultrasoft gluon
and but for the collinear
gluon, it's non-zero
and it's exactly, actually,
the same as the full theory.
It's the same as massless QCD.
So you can do the diagram
using the effective theory
Feynman rules, then
that's what you find.
But you could also
understand why that's true.
And reason why it's true is
nothing in this diagram really
specifies a frame.
We called all the
particles collinear,
but it's not
attached to anything.
So we could just take
the whole diagram
and boost back to the frame
where everything's kind of soft
and then we would usually be
thinking about it in terms
of a full theory field.
So that's effectively
why this diagram
like this that doesn't have
any reference, unlike this one
which has a reference
because it's
attached to the heavy quark.
That's why it's the same as QCD.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you know
what the epsilon position
for the Wilson line is set?
IAIN STEWART: Oh, for this one?
AUDIENCE: m bar dot k.
IAIN STEWART:
Yeah, for this one.
Yeah, for this guy it actually
doesn't depend on the i epsilon
prescription up to a--
yeah, if I remember correctly.
Yeah.
That's true, I
believe, when I'm being
a little bit cavalier with it
but once I put it the zero bin
restrictions, I'm not sure
if that's true anymore.
AUDIENCE: OK?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
I mean, really what solves
that is that in a minute
I'm going to be
talking about the fact
that there is a
subtraction term here
and once you put the
subtraction term in,
that i0 is not relevant.
But I think even if you do this
diagram with arbitrary i0--
because what's happening
is m bar dot k going to 0
is related to some of
these 1 over epsilons
and we'll talk about
that more in a minute.
Yeah, I'm not 100% sure.
It could be that there's
some sign that might flip.
I'm not 100% sure.
AUDIENCE: Even if they
get the wrong side,
the difference would
be subtraction.
IAIN STEWART: I
guess I know that--
yeah.
What I know is that--
yeah, let me answer
your question later.
It'll be easier
because I'm trying
to say a bunch of things
that depend on something else
that I haven't explained yet.
So what are the other possible
topologies we could write down?
So we could write
down this one, where
we take two attachments
in the Wilson line
and just loop them
back up but that's
proportional m bar
squared and so that's
0 in our Feynman gauge.
And likewise, there's a
looping back up in the vertex
in the wave function
renormalization,
but this guys scale is power
law divergent and so we can just
set it to 0 and dim reg.
You don't have to
worry about it.
OK, so that's all the diagrams.
Let's think about
doing matching,
i.e let's think about comparing
QCD and SCET by adding up
the diagrams.
In QCD we carried out
the randomization,
we added the z for
the tensor current.
Let me just write again
the answer looked like.
In SCET we didn't carry
out renormalization yet,
so let me call this the
bare SCET result for now.
Once we add the ultrasoft and
collinear diagrams together,
the logs of p squared match up
exactly with the full theory.
So this is the first sign
really that it makes sense
to be thinking about
adding these loops.
Even though they were
the same topology,
we are correctly
reproducing those logs of p
squared in the full theory.
And then there's
some other pieces.
I'll write out all
the other pieces
so you see what they look like.
Well, maybe I won't I
won't write the constant.
So there's all the effective
field theory terms.
So these terms here we can
match up with these terms here.
So that's good.
These terms here, which remember
in the full theory were finite,
and these terms here, which
in the effective theory,
are finite, the
difference of those
is going to give the
Wilson coefficient.
Now we said that the
Wilson coefficient
could be a function of p bar,
so what's going on with that?
Well, if you look at
momentum conservation
in this process
of beta s gamma--
so I probably should've
said this earlier.
So when you look
at beta s gamma,
if you look at momentum
conservation then
the p minus of the
strange quark has
to be equal to the p
minus of the b quark,
but that's just mb.
OK, so actually p minus is
equal to mb by kinematics.
So mb's in this result
here you shouldn't think
of as p minuses, and that's this
p bar that was in our Wilson
coefficient is just
getting set to mb
because of some delta functions
that are specifying kinematics.
So that leaves the 1
over epsilon terms.
And so what we'd like
is that those terms are
associated to renormalization.
Of the effective theory, right?
I wrote that the
effective theory was bare.
But if I want to do
that, then I have
to ensure that all
these epsilons that
are appearing here are really
ultraviolet divergences.
If they're infrared
divergences, then doing that
doesn't make sense.
And that's actually
the remaining issue
that we have to deal with.
I just wrote epsilon, that means
I'm ignorant to what they are.
And if I knew this
one was epsilon
IR because it came
from the wave function
renormalization
of the heavy quark
and that was the
same on both sides.
It was the same diagram,
it was the wave function
renormalization diagram in the
full and the effective theory.
So I could match up that one.
These ones just came
out, but it turns out
that so far with what we've
done, some of these epsilon
here are IR.
And so the IR divergences
aren't matching up
and the reason is
because we didn't
put in those restrictions
on our sum over labels.
OK.
So we have these restrictions,
k label not equal to zero
and k label not
equal to minus pl.
Those are the restrictions
that I'm talking about.
The place that those
restrictions came from
was k was the
momentum of the gluon.
kl not equal to 0 is saying
that this is the restriction
that the gluon is collinear.
Because kl equals 0
is the ultrasoft gluon
and this is the restriction
that the fermion is
collinear in the loop and that's
why there was two of them.
So these are called zero bins.
Zero because it's where the
ultrasoft momentum lives
and from the point of view
of collinear, that's zero.
Imposing these restrictions
is removing the zero
bin, if you like and what
these restrictions do
is they avoid double
counting and the way I've
said it that's, I think, clear.
So far in our calculation we
haven't avoided double counting
and that's the problem.
OK.
So we have to modify
our rule or we
extend our rule to
include the case where
we have these restrictions.
In an extended version of rule
two that house restrictions.
So really what we
want to do is that
and we want to think
about that as an integral.
So here's how we can
manipulate these to think
about it as an integral.
That sum over all
kl's, but then we'll
subtract the limit of
this f where we take the f
and we let the kl
go to the place.
So we integrate over
everywhere, including the place
we don't want to go, and
then we subtract it back.
So what is this fl of k?
This f of kl goes to 0.
it's defined by taking the
scaling limit of the collinear
momenta towards the ultrasoft.
So you take your
collinear momenta,
which are the minus
in the perp here,
and you scale them towards an
ultrasoft momentum in whatever
components, i.e you start
counting the kn's as order
lambda squared and you keep
the leading order piece
or you keep the piece that's
the same size as this term.
And then that defines
what this f is.
Once you take that
limit and you expand,
then that's what the f is.
So what you're doing here
by doing this procedure
is you're basically
setting things up
so that this guy is
integrated over in a way
that we can combine
back into an integral.
But then we have to
subtract an overlap
of when that integral would
go into the ultrasoft region.
But the overlap
we're subtracting
is also an integral, so we
have a difference of integrals.
And you should think
of the second integral
as integrating over the
square where the zero bin was.
So if you think
about our picture
where the collinears were up
here, ultrasofts are down here
and you thought about
there being some box,
you're taking this scaling
limit when this guy goes down
into that box.
You add up all the
boxes, that's this,
and then you subtract
out that box again.
And that avoids having a
double counting in that region.
So then this guy here, you
can do the same kind of trick
as before.
So continuing with the equation.
kl is going to 0, well, we can
think of it just as a function
of kr's.
And so effectively what
we get in the end is
an integral over
all k of f of k,
the full f, evaluated
with a continuous momentum
minus some f that's
expanded and avoids there
being overlap in this box.
So rather than having
these discrete sum
with the restriction, we have
a difference of integrals
and this subtraction term avoids
the overlap in that region.
So all the discrete
sums are good for is
a means of figuring out
what limits you need to take
to generate these subtractions.
Once you've done
that, everything's
a continuous integral.
And this is called the
zero bin subtraction.
OK, so if you like, one way
of phrasing what's going on
is that the collinear
propagators are really
distributions.
They're distributions
that know that they should
have a subtraction in order to
not overlap the other region
where we have another
degree of freedom.
So you can think
about it that way
and having this sum it's
just a way of encoding that.
But in the end, it looks like
some kind of plus function
where you have a subtraction.
AUDIENCE: So it seems
like in the second term
you would have to relearn the
expression because initially
in the [INAUDIBLE] k you
ignore kr minus and kr perps.
IAIN STEWART: I'll show you
how it works in an example
up there.
So let's go to our example.
Yeah, so what you just
said is not quite the way
you should think about it.
You should think
about it that you've
given the effective
theory f and now
I'm saying that that f, as
given, with its momentum as
given still has an overlap
with the ultrasoft region
that I want to subtract.
So I'm taking a
limit of that f, I'm
not add anything back to it.
So this guy, integral dk.
So this is what we wrote before.
And now if I take the ultrasoft
limit of it, of the k,
then I would write this.
OK?
So when I take
the scaling limit,
if you think about
k squared, k plus,
k minus, minus k perp squared,
when I take the scaling
limit of all momentum
being ultrasoft,
the components of the k
are still homogeneous.
So there's nothing
there to expand.
Some expansion happened
in this k plus p term.
One of our n bar dot k
changes its power counting,
but it's still n bar dot k.
There's nothing to expand there.
So this is what the
subtraction looks
like and then the
numerator, the n bar dot
k can be dropped
relative to the n bar dot
p, which is large and external.
OK, so this is taking the
ultrasoft limit of this.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have to subtract off
the the ultrasoft limit
of the quark as well?
IAIN STEWART:
Yeah, so in general
I would have to subtract off the
ultrasoft limit of the quark as
well.
And when I do that,
what I find is
a term that's power
suppressed and so I drop it.
But in general, I would
have to do that as well.
That's right.
And so it looks like
an ultrasoft diagram
except it's got this n bar
dot k inside of the v dot k
that we had in the
ultrasoft diagram.
And if you do a power counting
with the loop momentum
scaling as ultrasoft, then you
have this piece is of the order
the same size as
this piece and that's
why you keep only that term.
AUDIENCE: Do you have to
worry about a higher power?
IAIN STEWART: No.
So the prescription we have is
that we drop the higher powers
AUDIENCE: But if
I were to do say--
IAIN STEWART: Oh, if you
did the higher power--
AUDIENCE: --lower power
higher power zero bin?
IAIN STEWART: No.
So if we did the
higher power, then this
would start out at higher power.
And then when we
took the limit of it,
it would end up just starting
at that power or higher.
AUDIENCE: Right,
but there was a--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
you don't have to.
No.
AUDIENCE: No?
IAIN STEWART: No.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there a reason?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
so really what
you care about subtracting
here are the log divergences
and that's what this minimal
subtraction is doing.
By keeping the piece that's
scaling the same way,
you're removing the
log divergent pieces.
And it's the log
divergent pieces which
are giving one of our epsilons.
The pieces that you would get
from the higher expansion,
they would all be kind of
like power law divergent terms
from the point of view
of the power counting
and we just don't have
to worry about those.
And another way of
saying it is, it's not
that I'm removing absolutely
this whole integrand
in that region, right?
There could still be a
constant, for example,
that comes from that region.
But if there's a constant
that comes from that region,
I don't care.
What I care about removing is
any spare use IR singularities.
And for those I can make
a minimal subtraction,
which is just the first term.
All right, so I want to
finish this discussion.
So if we do this,
we get an answer,
which I will try to write
on the board for you.
So now I'm going to
distinguish all the epsilons
and then we'll see what
this subtraction does.
So if I was careful and I
distinguished all the epsilons
in our original calculation,
it'd actually look like this.
And then the subtraction piece
gives an extra contribution
and it's actually scaleless
in the n bar dot k here.
So there's a scaleless
loop in this guy.
So it actually vanishes if the
epsilon IR and the epsilon UV
are said to be equal.
But what it does is it
converts the epsilon IRs that
are in the first expression
into epsilon UVs, which
is what we want.
So once you add up
these two things,
the epsilon IRs are
canceling and the epsilon IRs
that were coming in the
original formula, those
were coming about because
of this bad behavior
as n bar dot k goes into
the limit of n bar dot
k going small.
You can think about that roughly
as where the ultrasoft is.
This is subtracting off that
behavior and the remainder
then is coming from only
having divergences for a n bar
dot k goes to infinity, which is
a proper collinear ultraviolet
divergence not from n
bar dot k going to 0.
So once you put
the two together,
the epsilon IRs cancel
and then we get exactly,
actually, the same expression
we had before but where
all those 1 over epsilons
are 1 over epsilon UVs.
AUDIENCE: So the epsilon
has come from second term?
IAIN STEWART: From both terms.
So they both have epsilon IRs
but they cancel between them.
AUDIENCE: OK.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
And the remainder is
just epsilon UVs, so
all the epsilons that I wrote
my earlier formula would
be now epsilon UVs once I take
into account the subtraction.
So I could have just ignored
the subtraction and that's
often what people do.
If they know that the zero
bins are giving a scaleless
integral, they say, well,
let's ignore the subtraction,
we'll just say that
all the epsilons are UV
and the zero bin makes them UV.
But if we really
want to look and see
that things are
working properly,
we should take the subtraction
and calculate it and make sure
that that's true.
But we could have
just taken the answer
that I wrote down earlier
and said those epsilons are
ultraviolet and let's
throw them in a counterterm
and calculate an
anomalous dimension.
So we'll proceed
that way next time,
but we now know
that actually they
are ultraviolet divergences.
So next time we'll take
the ultraviolet divergences
and we'll define from
them a counterterm
And we'll see how we get
an anomalous dimension
and what kind of logs we sum by
using that anomalous dimension.
So the zero bin that's scaleless
in this particular example
is not always scaleless.
So sometimes it
could give a nonce.
Depends on the problem
you're dealing with.
So sometimes you can set things
up so that it's scaleless
and then you just
basically can ignore it.
But that's not
always true, so you
do have to think about whether
it's really going to be
true for what you're doing.
If it is true, then
you can effectively
ignore it because it's
sort of just making
the physics come out right,
making sure there's no overlap.
But if your regulators set
up so that it's scaleless,
you can just get around it.
But in general, that
might not be true.
If you had more
scales in the problem,
if you're doing some
calculation that
had some jets of
finite size then that
won't be true typically.